صحيح أننا نتابع الأخبار العاجلة
من إيران
بشأن اغتيال ، دعنا نصل إلى نيك
بايتون والش
الذي لديه تفاصيل ما حصلنا عليه في
هذه المرحلة ،
لكن ما
يبدو أن وسائل الإعلام الحكومية
تركز عليه الآن مع بعض عناصر
اليقين هو ذلك
عالم نووي معروف في إيران سيصل إلى
تاريخه المهني في لحظة
يبدو أن موسن فخرزادي قد
قُتل يبدو
في هجوم على سيارته في
ضواحي طهران
بمنطقة خضراء أه بالقرب من التلال القريبة كانت
هناك بعض الصور  يظهر على وسائل الإعلام الحكومية
التي يبدو
أنها تُظهر هذا المشهد بالذات لماذا يكون
هذا الرجل مهمًا جدًا بشكل خاص
إذا بدا أنه توفي في الواقع
متأثرًا بجروح كما يبدو الآن أن
عددًا من تقارير وسائل الإعلام الحكومية
تشير إلى أنه في الواقع هو وبعض
من  نُقل حراسه الشخصيون
إلى المستشفى واستسلموا
لإصاباتهم ،
ومن المحتمل أن يكون ذلك بمثابة ضربة
لهيبة إيران مرة أخرى
بالتأكيد ، ثم أيضًا إذا استمعت إلى
الاتهامات  من قبل الإسرائيليين
ومؤخراً في العام الماضي من
قبل وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية يحتمل
أن تكون بمثابة ضربة لما
يقولون إنها جهود إيران المستمرة
لامتلاك سلاح نووي تذكر الكثير من الجدل
حول ما إذا كان التزام إيران
بالاتفاق النووي في عام 2015 أم لا.  لقد
أوقف دونالد ترامب الذي خرج من هذه الصفقة في الواقع تقدمهم نحو
سلاح
يبدو أن معظم الموقعين عليه يعتقدون ذلك ،
ولكن منذ
أن أخرج دونالد ترامب الولايات المتحدة من تلك الصفقة إلى
استياء
الحلفاء الأوروبيين ، فمن الواضح تمامًا في
البيانات العامة أن إيران قد
سرعت  التخصيب المحتمل تجاه
المجالات التي من شأنها أن تجعل
هؤلاء الموقعين على التعامل غير مريح للغاية ،
وقد تم ذكر هذا الرجل محسن فخر زاده في
عدد من الوثائق كما ينبغي أن أقول إنه
أظهر ki
في خطاب ألقاه في أغسطس 2018 من قبل
بنيامين نتنياهو رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
حيث أوضح ما  قال إنها مجموعة
من
الملفات مأخوذة أساسًا من
أرشيفات إيران والتي أظهرت تاريخيًا
ما كانت عليه حتى كيف  لقد كانوا على
وشك الحصول على سلاح ،
اعتبر الكثيرون أن هذا الخطاب في ذلك الوقت
كان محاولة من جانب إسرائيل
لدفع الإدارة الرابحة
إلى مزيد من الإجراءات لتشويه
سمعة الاتفاق النووي الذي
كان الجانب الإسرائيلي المتشدد يكره دائمًا
ما نراه للتو.  كانوا يقرؤون
في الواقع في تقرير وزارة الخارجية
في
أواخر العام الماضي ، يقولون إن إيران لديها
جهود للاحتفاظ بسجلات من
برنامج الأسلحة النووية السابق
، وينسبون الفضل إلى خطاب نتنياهو
لتسليط الضوء على ذلك ،
حيث يشيرون إلى القيادة
المستمرة للرئيس السابق لذلك البرنامج موسان.
وأشار فخرازادي إلى
أن إيران احتفظت بمعلومات من
مساعيها التاريخية للمساعدة في أي
قرار مستقبلي للسعي وراء أسلحة نووية
إذا تم اتخاذ قرار للقيام بذلك
بوضوح داخل
جهاز المخابرات للولايات المتحدة
وعلى الأرجح إسرائيل أيضًا
رأوا أن هذا
الرجل  مفتاح مطلق من حيث
المعرفة الآن
لماذا إذا تبين أن
تقارير وسائل الإعلام الحكومية هذه صحيحة وهناك
إيحاءات بأنه من المحتمل أن يكون قد أصيب
والتي ستلعب في الساعات القادمة
إرتباك مفهوم مع
شخصية بهذا الحجم إذا بدا
أنه قتل في الواقع
في منطقة حماية إيران حول
طهران رجل مع حراسه
أه اغتال إصبع  ستشير الشكوك
بالطبع في البداية إلى إسرائيل
التي لم تقل شيئًا
على خشبة المسرح بشأن هذا الأمر ، لكن
سيكون ذلك مرة أخرى محرجًا
لإيران نظرًا
لفقدانها أبرز شخصية عسكرية لديها قاسم
سليماني
قائد الحرس الثوري الإيراني
في نفس الوقت في وقت سابق من هذا العام
وبالمثل.  كنت ستفكر في
فقاعة آمنة أثناء سفره
في العراق إذا كان هذا الرجل الوحيد قد استهدف في الواقع
من قبل القتلة ، مما
قد يوحي
بأن هناك بالتأكيد تسربًا
للمعلومات داخل الدوائر النووية الإيرانية الأكثر أمانًا
أيضًا ، عليك أن تسأل
نفسك
رقمًا جيدًا  المعروف باسم هذا يظهر في
العديد من
تقارير هيئة الرقابة النووية
وتقارير وزارة الخارجية حول
كيفية الإبلاغ عن كثب  إذا كان سيبقى
جيدًا ، فقد قيل إنه من المحتمل أن
يشارك في جزء من
قسم تطوير العلوم في الحرس الثوري
للنظر في ما قد يفعلونه في
المستقبل ، وأعتقد هنا أنه عليك أن
تنظر بالضبط إلى ما يمكن أن تكون عليه اللعبة
النهائية لقتل مثل هذا  في الواقع ،
إذا كنت تتطلع إلى دفع صقور إيران
إلى موقف غير مريح هنا ،
فهذا بالتأكيد يفعل ذلك وإذا كنت
تتطلع إلى هز القارب أه تعكير
المياه قبل
أن يأتي الرئيس الأمريكي المنتخب بيدن
في يناير
من المؤكد أن مثل هذا سيضع دعمًا
للناس على
الرغم من أنه بصراحة أنه
محرج إلى حد ما لإيران بدلاً من
حثهم على القيام
بشيء مثير للاهتمام
حقًا إنه بالتأكيد يركز فقط
أذهان الجميع على مدى أهمية
البرنامج النووي الإيراني
والعطاءات في المنطقة.
لتقليص ذلك هو في الواقع بيكي